so this year's laureates Tosca Hangzhou
was born in Kyoto in 1942 this was
during the World War two so these were
really difficult times the family moved
around quite a lot but Anya managed to
make it through so in the 1960s he
started medicine at the Kyoto University
and became MD in 99 and 1966 he spent
the next years in the Graduate School in
the same University
after that he went to the US during 1971
72 he was a fellow at the Carnegie
Institution of Washington in Baltimore
and later he worked at NIH in 1979 he
became professor at Osaka University and
thereafter at the Department of Medical
Chemistry Kyoto University where he
later served as Dean from steer he is
distinguished professor at the Kyoto
University Institute for Advanced Study
and from this year he is also the deputy
director-general when I first met with
the Tosca NGO many years ago he was
interested in working on cloth switch
recombination in B lymphocytes and
trying to understand the process he also
succeeded in finding the reason and he
identified the new protein this protein
was named activation induced cited in
deaminase and this crucial enzyme was
not only important for switching the
clause but it also causes somatic
hypermutation and this is important to
make antibodies work really well
I also remember listening to seminar in
the 1990s when he mentioned about PD one
the importance of which was not at award
understood at that time his discoveries
related to PD one originate from its
identification and all the way through
the understanding of its role as a
checkpoint inhibitor and of course
antibodies directed against this
molecule have become highly important
cancer drugs
dr. Hondo has received many awards and I
will mention a few he has received the
imperial price and the Japan Academy
prize he's a foreign associate of the US
National Academy of Sciences and member
of the German academy of natural
scientists in 2012 he received the
Robert Koch price he has received the
order of Culture Japan the tank prize
and in 2016 the Kyoto prize he has also
received the ko medical science prize
and the Warren Alpert foundation price
Tosca Anjou likes music and painting he
has tells me that he always tries to
visit museums and go to concerts when
traveling he made an attempt to play the
flute but it didn't really work out so
you gave it up but tasks evangelized
essentially all types of exercise such
as tennis baseball basketball table
tennis and golf
he takes golf quite seriously and his
handicap is 14 he told me yesterday that
he every year he plays a few times with
Shinya Yamanaka Nobel laureate in 2012
when his father was also doctor similar
to Allison's he was a surgeon he was a
good painter and played tennis and golf
very well
similar to Jim Allison there were things
happening in during also during Hondo's
school period in Honda's case as a child
his teachers did not perceive him as a
good obedient pupil this was because he
often asked very difficult questions
since reading regular textbooks never
really satisfied him one day a young
female teacher even began to cry when he
pointed out that she might be wrong
since then he stopped asking questions
in school and instead he decided to read
books other than textbooks by himself
and of course today we are the ones
that read about Tosca Honda's
discoveries please welcome this year's
laureate Tuscany
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You professor
Aerosmith's for your kind introduction a
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen I'm extremely honored and
humbled to have the opportunity to give
Noble
another lecture at the current Square
Institute for this I had free appreciate
the enormous efforts of the novel
Assembly of the current sky Institute
the title of my talk Serendipity's of
acquired immunity as your meaning a
represent not only my contribution to
cancer is rather for teachers but also
all human beings fortunate to have
acquired immunity aquatic immunity
otherwise Ken Simon therapy must have
been impossible I was born in Kyoto in
1942 my family has generated many
medical doctors my surgeon my father was
a surgeon and had a rather strict
educator on the other hand my mother is
so beautiful and always warm-hearted she
has been the my guardian goddess until
she passed away five five years the
first incidence when I was charmed by a
natural science
took place at the playground of the
elementary school then I watched this
tiny tiny ring of Sodom through the
telescope the picture you recently see
is more fantastic and likely you can see
even the earth from sudden through the
recent technical development by Cassini
I was very much fascinated by astronomy
and I read many books and see very what
seriously wanted to become astronomer I
read many books but my enthusiam
enthusiasm gradually faded away when my
mother kept a book of biography of
Noguchi hideo now which she is kind of
self educated doctor
he moved United States at age of 23 or
so and hired as a professor in
Rockefeller University and identified
syphilis vaccine as a cause of
progressive paralysis unfortunately he
died in Ghana during pursuit of arrow
fever pathogens but I'm very much
impressed his strong spirits and hiring
activities so I went to medical school
in Kyoto
there I'm a game very fortunate to meet
or some Hayashi my mentor who discovered
the gas oxygen can be directly in cope
into organic organic compounds by the
enzyme oxidase he spent nine years in
United States and came back establish
the Department of Biochemistry which is
well I kept it and also he provided very
international atmosphere thanks to that
I had an occasion to discuss with Jack
mano in very early stage in my career I
was also very fortunate as soon after I
went in the graduate course I picked up
the interesting paper by John career he
says Geoff theory toxin in activates
protein synthesis elongation factor ef-2
and this reaction requires respiratory
coenzyme nad I was very much fascinated
and tried find out what's a mechanism of
nad I was very fortunate
Nishioka at that time in high reaches
love later she found the protein c
kinase he made lots of nad derivatives
with radio label compounds and i found
actually Jeff theory toxin is the enzyme
that catalyzes ATP ribosomal transfer to
elongation factor 2 and this way the
enzyme is inactivated with this very
fortunate start of my career
I'm also very fortunate to meet Donna
Braun in Carnegie Institution wasn't an
embodiment
he is a person who opened my eyes to the
molecular immunology he explained to me
their long history not only immunology
but biology antibody diversity is now on
the table
we can now tackle this big question by
modern molecular balance called
technology like reverse transcriptase
the mystery of immune response around
1970 is very attractive to everybody the
question is how can animals generate
antibodies specific to almost infinite
number of antigens including artificial
chemicals like Karl Landsteiner he took
any compounds on his shelf conjugated
with protein inject animals and then he
could prove animals can generate
antibody against the chemicals so-called
hapten with high specificity so people
thought wow animal may have endless
number of immunoglobulin genes that's
obviously impossible the structure of
antibody which was originally identified
from varying and Sheba Sbrocco Sato or
gradually becoming clear number of
scientists involved Paul Ehrlich also
studied lot and most directory Gerald
Edelman Rodney Potter found antibodies
composed to heavy chain to light chain
they are linked by disulphide bond
Hirshman and craig and also putnam
discovered light chain is composed and a
terminal variable and c-terminal concern
region and obviously the variable region
is responsible for antigen recognition
and concern region responsible various
activity of antibody to process the
capture of the antigens so the question
is how many regions how many seasons the
dawn gave very attractive idea of
multiple V and market the C but
obviously this is the hypothesis so I
was very fortunate don't introduce me to
fill leaders laboratory in NIH and he
hired me as a postdoc I moved there and
worked very hard and after few years we
reached the conclusion immunoglobin
light chain either Kappa or lambda has
only one at most of you genes the
results ironically suggests Don's idea
is wrong there must be limited number of
the see region and therefore another
indication is to explain the large
number with a variable region expression
animal should have genetic alteration
either somatic hypermutation or
recombination or both ensure enough four
years later
Susumu tonegawa found to generate larger
repertoire of a maneuver
even the four light chain vj4 heavy
chain DJ components we assembled during
differentiation and by combinatorial
mechanism they generate enormous
diversity and he was awarded Nobel Prize
87 I believe meantime I decided to go
back to Japan and got a position in
University of Tokyo there after long
thinking I decided to pick up different
project but still I wanted understand
the immunoglobin diversification as my
serious question instead of continuing
the same series of study using a light
chain I switched to the heavy chain
which has obviously different questions
this is related repeated immunization so
called vaccination so people already
knew after repeated immunization there
are two interesting of the vision one is
the change of the title affinity to the
antigen and this is due to the somatic
hypermutation the b-cell change the
variable region rather randomly and one
of the highest affinity expressing these
cells selected by antigen and this is
the mechanism of antigen induced high
affinity maturation the Alpha mechanism
is class switching the initial antibody
generated memory IgM but after repeated
injections
IgG become dominant the cloths which is
a change of the concentration rather
than V region and that produced from IgM
to IgA IgG IgE and each has different
function and different location and V
region surprisingly remain constant how
this captain and both are antigen driven
so we decided pick up this question and
we are very fortunate to find to make
class switching big chunk of DNA on the
chromosome deleted to express one
particular C gene from IgM IgG to a you
have to delete a big DNA and that
intervening segment is grouped out and
this was done with the help of bright
medical student in Korea University Toru
kataoka and Akira see Meisel and we also
determined the order of the CH Dean
along the chromosome which we
hypothesized soon after we came to
Sweden and met unum your're the food
mattias wobble many others who compete
each other for cloning amino group in
lockers and found almost simultaneously
reached a similar conclusion but still
we have many questions we haven't solved
mechanism for somatic hypermutation and
also most importantly what the enzyme to
mediate such interesting genetic
alteration and we also fortunate to
obtain original say
trova cell which can be stimulated from
IgM to IG a with cd40 lion
art for TV of bitter and Masamichi
Mohammed's
came and try to see the difference
between stimulated not stimulated and
they found new gene called activation in
decided in the army needs a ID which is
specifically expressed Germany center
b-cells involved for class switch
recombination probably and we made a
knockout and the knockout animals showed
strong induction of IgM by immunization
but IgG showing a blue is totally absent
in air D deficient animals in addition
hyper mutation is also disproved in air
D deficient animals and no hyper
mutation as compared heterozygote AI D
animals our collaborator in France and
Ronnie and Aaron Fisher also found any
human cohort patient of hyper IGM
syndrome type 2 they all had a mutation
the same gene AI D and we published the
paper on side by side and together a ID
is the enzyme that engraves antigen
memory in the antibody gene and this is
the mechanistic basis for vaccination so
taken together
Susumu tonegawa showed the rabbit of a
generation by putting vdj together and
mature B so my greater periphery and see
the pathogen induce a ID and that
mediate have a mutation and class rating
well occasionally
here it is apparently induced and cause
tumor and this is very rare because most
of the immunology told immune activation
rather suppress tumor growth
the idea of cancer immunotherapy dates
back to the last century but the very
hypothetical backbone of can't
immunotherapy immune surveillance was
proposed by Sir Frank MacFarlane Burnet
1970 and because of this very strong
hypothetical background large number of
people try to demonstrate by activating
immune system tumor can be suppressed or
treated and unfortunately as you heard
from Jim it was very difficult the trial
includes many different types first many
people isolated and purified cancer
specific proteins called no antigens and
produced in abundance injected as a
vaccine another trials in which
reactivation of T lymphocyte using il-2
and putting back to the same patient
also worth injection of cytokines like
interferon gamma L 2 L 12 or failure
retrospectively all these trial or to
push axial and unfortunately immune
system was totally under the strong
break induced by tumor growth
to identify the immune system break came
only 1995 when Jim Allison showed CTL
for is kind of the parking brake
paired with city city 28 is ignition
molecule and I think this is a comparing
like parking brake and directs on/off
rather drastic regulation we identify
the PD one as a brake and accelerator I
cause pairing and rather mild smooth
regulation of the immune system the
moment we encounter the PD one was very
fortunate I'm very fortunate or over so
yes Massa Ishida came to my department
what it identified thymus selection
mechanism namely something involved cell
death and he actually cloned the cDNA by
subtraction and found this surface
molecule hydrophobic regions and
intracellular domain contains highly
conserved tyrosine molecules and to
tyrosine is a very well known at that
time for activation signaling molecules
but these two titles in MPD one are
different the distance between two a
double compare the rest of the known
activation molecule so we are convinced
there are something different
interesting but I don't know so we
decided to make knockout and knockout
done by Nishimura and others and that's
the beginning of the law
struggle first knockout born rather soon
but couldn't see any phenotypic change
dr. Minato advised to back rows to the
homozygote again no phenotypic change we
could see some over response to antigen
stimulation may be some negative
regulator but not so clear but it took
almost six seven years until we find
clear nephritis of arthritis by crossing
with LPR air pure background which is
all immune prong five weeks after in
case of CT a four by four weeks every
single animal died so this is a very
mild and chronic and clear at immunity
in PD one knockout by only 14 months so
I don't know whether Nishimura watched
every day I don't think so she left the
mice for months and one day she found
this so anyway we found PD one knockout
in blood mice shows nephritis arthritis
white mouse called the myopathy and
crossed with the odium from background
and OD MLL all XS a very very severe
phenotype we are very much convinced
this is the negative regulator because
we release the break immune system goes
up Taku Okazaki photo showed the
mechanism by crossing PD one with T cell
receptor signal induced by antigen
recognition it's force waited
and pd1 also get phosphorylate and
recruit phosphatase that defaults for it
one by one so this way the reaction is
reduced now we find all this mechanism
obvious thing is immune system in
balance with accelerator and brake and
no Murray if it's a balance it's okay if
it goes to the hyper amina activity it's
good for infectious diseases treatment
and cancer treatment but risk of
autoimmunity so if we push broke the
brake and push the axle we have a chance
to cure the cancer so we try this the
first experiment I asked yoshikawa is to
compare PD one deficient animal and
while animal see whether Timo can grow
differently the reason I chose this
instead of antibody is because I don't
trust the antibody because there are
many antibodies I trust the genetics so
what we found sorry is here compared the
wild-type PD one deficiency well this is
the last published data but anyway the
first error she showed was convincing
and we think PD one the efficiency or
blockade is good for suppressing tumor
growth so I doctor minato and he already
started making antibody against the PDL
1 and also PD one but PD L 1 is the best
antibody available and he could clearly
demonstrate antibody blockade also
suppress tumor growth and even prolong
the survival
our new Yoshio I further went on to show
the metastasis of the melanoma injection
into spleen to liver and liver this is
rather normal and this is metastatic
liver and you can say by weight and
color under PD untreated animal shows
much less metastatic liver
so both PD one blockade or PDL one
blockade we can cure the cancer and the
mechanism we still don't know some
people claim tumor Express Ligon and we
block here but PDL 1 is expressed
everywhere almost all ABC Express so how
the CTL become suppressed we still don't
know but anyway the key molecule is PD
one and either Ligon or receptive
blockade can cure the cancer so we
wanted put this into the clinic and we
need lots of money and lots of the
technologies we are very fortunate
medics found our published patent and
approached us and studied generate anti
PD one human antibody and the product is
IgG for and point mutation to prevent
antibody dependent survey etcetera
basicity and named Neve Oman and this
antibody was approved by FDA
investigation new drug was first to 2006
and then we can start crink
trial about that time I met a famous
scientist rock this guy and you know so
this was a very unfortunate incident and
then the animal our clinical trial went
on rather smoothly and the first report
was published 2012 by Susan - partying
and result was amazing this was all
spread all over the world newing Journal
Medicine paper came out and Wall Street
Journal and Frankfurt argument are all
the front line of first page so basic
message to one all the patient recruited
to a terminal stage patient with solid
tumor big tumor melanoma lung cancer
renal cancer and surprisingly twenty to
eight twenty to thirty percent patient
responded complete or partial on top of
that those who once responded still
respond years the treatment stopped
after two years but still they respond
continued to stay we did our own
clinical trial in small scale in Kyoto
in collaboration John ecology department
and patient or Platon resistant ovarian
cancer and here again if we include
stable disease as a disease control rate
it reached to the 40 to 50 percent and
among them we are very much impressed
the lady for responded very quickly and
become a completely tumor free and this
lady
even after we stopped the treatment
after one year
remain tumor-free more than four years
and another case more than 3.5 years
tumor free so without treatment this can
last there is very very ideal the most
impressive quicker trial using me Bowman
published 2015 by international
collaboration many European countries
Australia Canada and they showed
comparison of NIMH ovum and chemo
typical chemo dacarbazine it's a random
trial so it's a blind test and patient
who received Nouveau mom almost 70%
survived after year and a half on the
other hand chemo treated patient less
than 20% so though it's a drastic
difference the huge number of clinical
trials I don't have time to mention but
because of this the PD one locate
therapy is now approved over dozen type
of cancers even this year cervical
cancer and primary mediastinal large
b-cell lymphoma and as Jim mentioned
striking all highly mutated cancers it
can detect easily by micro satellite or
the deficiency of mismatch repair enzyme
regardless the origin of tumor tissues
this is very very important so taking
together
the PD one treatment opinion treatment
brought paradigm shift in cancer therapy
first less adverse effects because
normal cells are almost untouched
secondary effective for wide range of
tumors more than thousand clinical
trials are still ongoing thirdly it
shows durable effects you can stop the
treatment and they can last at least
four to five years why this is so
effective we already heard enormous
amount of investigators sequenced the
cancer genome the published studying
melanoma to breast cancer or thyroid
cancer
all of them accumulate mutations each
spot is one sample so this is a log
scale plot of coding mutation and normal
cell has no mutation so all tumors has
either thousand times or 10,000 times
higher mutation in coding region that
leads to the expression of new antigen
we call new antigen and those new
antigen are different from our original
protein and that is recognized by immune
system so what we learn is this cancer
cell mutate and make new antigen
secondary mutations are so frequent it's
very difficult to pinpoint what is
dominant mutations or what is a
secondary mutation and
because of this cancer cell continuously
mutate and you give the chemo they
change and give rise to resistant
Crohn's another drug another resistant
Crohn's and fortunately lymphocyte can
recognize all these resistant mutants
and can attack them this is the big
advantage now I told you very very
promising outcome but this is not the
end of the story you know we have many
many problems first of all clearly only
20 to 30 percent patient respond so we
have to distinguish responders from non
responders how we can do it
one is high mutagenesis in tumors which
I mentioned but this is also not always
most important point is potency of
individuals immunity
some puke when flu virus you get some
people sneeze and that's all others get
48 very high fever and almost die so
enormous variation among individual and
this is very difficult because it's not
just MHC gene
there are hundreds genes involved in
immune power
we also have to deal with improvement of
immunotherapy or free not 20 to 30% of
free to 80 to 90 percent and actually
there are two aspects one is access
severity of killer t-cell to tumor site
the other is potency of carousel
function itself I'd like to briefly
mention about the first aspect candy
tamata in my lab found that tumor cell
first attacked by resident Kiera T so by
PD one blockade and this stimulation
give the gamma interferon and tumor cell
itself secrete some chemical and this
also leaves activated T's in lymph node
migrate to the tumor site so PT one
blockade takes place to position one in
tumor site but it's number is very
limited but most important is activation
of karate so in lymph node that activate
chemical receptor and also
differentiation and this is very
important process so often surgeon
removes many lymph node sounding lymph
tumor but that's not good idea you have
to keep intact if not and he showed in
animal experiment if you remove draining
lymph node even if we inject anti pd-1
that tumor cannot be reduced tumor keep
growing
now as Jim said now many people trying
to combine with PD one with CT
four and chemo radiotherapy and bgf a
and Okun combination so thousand
combinatorial trial going on and we hope
there will be something very promising
come out in a few years we also try new
approach in our case we know that T
lymphocyte 1 get activated needs lots of
energy and lots of compounds energy
depends on mitochondria and so we
screened chemicals which might be able
to boost my country and it may attack
the tumor more efficiently we and others
showed P DC 1 alpha co transcription
factor couple ways people are signaling
activates essential step in mitochondria
activation oxidative phosphorylation and
fatty acid consumption in fact better
fit braids together with anti PDL one
antibody in animal tumor model the
effect of the antibody is further
enhanced synergistically so this is
promising
so we now on clinical trial in Japan
Kyushu University and the common water
university and high we hope the results
relatively soon the mechanism the two
whole one is the better fit a paper
signaling promote increased
proliferation generation effect a killer
T cells and also they enhance the
perforation into memory generation
instead of exhaustion and service by
these two mechanism pres afib rate
combination PD one blockade increase
number of killer T cells in tumor site
so I'd like to add a little bit of
wallet
adverse effect of the PD want efficiency
Sidonia Fidelis on in weekend together
with the from each Komatsu that showed
pd-1 deficient animal show serum level
reduction of treat for metabolism method
mitochondria activation related
compounds so it grows so rapidly they
consume essential amino acid and madcon
you're turning on very rapidly they can
monitored in serum an actually this
enormous expansion and consumption
metabolites effects even the brain
neurotransmitter level like serotonin
and dopamine and induce behavior change
and she fathers showed this is related
with gut bacteria change earlier
Ferguson's group showed PD one
deficiency reduce high affinity iga
production IG a that combined good
bacteria mean efficient for symbiosis
and they lose such a iga production and
change microbiota spectrum in the gut
less anaerobic bacteria and increase the
Enterobacter like e-coli and this will
in turn stimulate host immune system an
actually to make high affinity IgA you
need a ID another my favorite molecule
in germinal center cut germinal center
PD one on t-cell interact with PD lichen
on bezel and if P cell can capture good
antigen and presents strong stimuli to
t-cell they cannot proliferate they can
offer the help to be so produce good
antibody so only P cell which can
produce high affinity iga get this
selection by T so in germinal Center and
that good for controlling gut Mac
bacteria in fact pack 2002 so Nia
Vardalos on showed first time added
efficiency skewed gut micro micro buta
and expansion segmented favored
5:5 filamentous bacteria like this and
this course an almost expansion of the
power patch on the gut and even the
spleen is enlarged so gut microbiota is
very critical to control the level of
the host immune system so we asked the
question PD one deficiency definitely
have hyper team activity how about air D
deficiency the result just
pd-1 deficiency air D deficiency has
strong anti-tumor activity even without
pd-1 blockade
this is just straight animal and this
separation of tumor grows in air the
deficiency is bacteria dependent because
in germ free condition they don't show
any difference so what's happening is
pd-1 and air D should collaborate to
produce appropriate IgA to control gut
microbiota and this balance is important
to maintain in intolerance and
homeostatic balance of metabolome
improbably brain condition but once this
balance is destroyed either pd-1
deficiency or AI D deficiency they
cannot produce appropriate IgA to
control microbiota and it may enhance
the anti-tumor activity but on the other
side they cause some emotional or
behavioral defect and also Ottoman
diseases so we clearly don't know much
about the whole body regulation and we
have to learn more and more 2016 an
equivalent code it don't chain saying we
just discovered cancer equivalent
penicillin
although the penicillin itself couldn't
cure all infections it gave rise to a
whole generation of antibiotics that
change the medicine forever
consigning most previously fatal
infections to history
so I hope this will be true currently
they still immunotherapy is minor
fraction of the cancer treatment but
because of enormous efforts of the
number of the people it will eventually
grow and more and more cancers may be
treated by immunotherapy and someday I
don't know whether it's a 2030 or not
cancer may not completely disappear but
be controlled by immunotherapy cancer
may become one of the chronic diseases
if you still have a tumor but no growth
that's okay
especially for elderly people
you can keep your quality of life now
last century we eradicated infectious
diseases by vaccination and antibiotics
and this century
I hope canceled we control by
immunotherapy its improvement including
as I mentioned microbiome manipulation
had said at the beginning our quail
immunity is critical a quite immunity
evolved in vertebrates as a defense
system against the pathogens
consequently the lifespan of the
vertebrates expanded dramatically that's
why we are here fortunately cancer cells
are cumulative adhesions and Express new
antigens which can also be recognized by
acquired immunity so this must be the
bonus of evolution
finally I like to thank my collaborators
I cannot mention all of the people
involved some people well I think it's
too much because there are more people
than I could list
I leave the so long so I I also many
people and this is the also the list of
the funding agency who support me for a
long term well thank you for your
attention
[Music]
[Applause]